[Music]
we got a million people friends you come
here and [ __ ] with us [ __ ]
you see me at mike no no but your seat
right here
your seat is right here [ __ ] right here
[Music]
another great episode of hot boxing with
mike tyson and
evan britton and listen we got an
episode here [ __ ] this is the episode
man
we got the wonderful whack 100 [ __ ]
whack talk to us man
100
i'm in the build man you know my man
people been telling me mike been in town
you know
all right i live here now i live here
i don't know why they was telling me
that they kept telling me yo mike's
eddie in town
you know i grew up watching mike with
people ass and then
he kind of inspired me to kind of fight
the way i was fighting so
you know i didn't know if mike was in
town he was looking for me if he wanted
to talk to me
if he wanted to do something to me nah i
was just like i'm gonna go down there if
he
if he want to fight [ __ ] it we just
gonna fight not for real
no i love you [ __ ] i'm here with mike
hey listen one thing about mike
he always embrace the culture he never
went hollywood on us even when he was
bigger than hollywood
you could see mike pulling up at a
jack-in-the-box getting out going into
the joint by himself
you know what i'm saying so i don't know
if he was just crazy
well we thought he was crazy we damn
sure we're gonna try to fight him and by
all means we wanted to protect mike
tyson
that's all it was thomas it was just
what it was
man i just love seeing the black
[ __ ] in the hood [ __ ] it's just
not
like it yeah if you got some money too
it's oh [ __ ]
man it's just you're a king yeah the
trip
you know what i mean and this is really
oh cause i'm young right you see
sometimes
i'm not good with rapping with girls
when i'm young right so
i see a girl hey whoa she's looking at
my car would you like that car
you know you like that this is your car
now just come with me
and that's how listen man ain't tricking
if you got it you know what i'm saying
you know at the end of the day and
that's what's so awesome about the black
community [ __ ]
you want that [ __ ] mercedes
baby
she could have just left the house
husband just cooked their breakfast and
all that
but she and that toyota torcel might
talk about you want that benz
you know what i'm saying and he meant
that you know what i mean
and you're gonna be all right too if you
think he's gonna be all right knockout
you're not gonna be [ __ ] limping and
hurting no you're gonna be cool you'll
be happy you wanna come by again
you might get an apartment next time and
you know what we gotta establish our
punch line too you know
i'm wack 100 i'm very controversial on
the things i say i mean the things i say
i say something tell them who you are
you know who you are most people won't
say
so i'ma say this because i'm ride with
mike right or wrong
this is the punch line you're gonna hear
periodically
when i just get mad and upset and i
think about it but everybody it's going
to go viral but it's what it is
i got a bald head i can't grow my hair
so it was like this
[ __ ] don king that's it i said that
y'all know what time it is you ratchet
[ __ ]
you know what it is and that's what it
is [ __ ] don king
and we're gonna keep it like that that's
interesting somebody told me [ __ ]
king the other night when i was in vegas
because we ride with you
mike you know hey listen ain't got to
say but know what i learned in life this
is what i learned and learned it i'm
late in life too
let [ __ ] go man you know listen we had
to let you go
see you let it go you let it go
see mike still wanna respect about mike
is because he represent
being all the way up knocked all the way
down we talking about incarceration
we ain't talking about going bankrupt we
talking about incarceration
then coming back home right and jumping
back in the ring
right and doing his thing but he wasn't
the same
mike he thought he was when he left and
didn't happen to figure this [ __ ] out
again right
so when everybody thought it was over
with everybody was cracking the jokes
oh mike and vegas doing this mike got a
comedy show what the [ __ ] up with mike
and we sit here and we look at mike
right now today right
a lot of those people that was talking
they don't even got a platform to talk
on but right now we still talking on
mike's platform
brother serene whether it's it's a
resort regardless of what it is mike
doing a lot of things in this world he
blessing a lot of people
you know what's coming that comes down
to brother that's just not giving up you
know how this world and sometimes people
who we think are friends
they see we go down they think we're
never going to come back no that's real
they think it's over
they think there's nothing we can do for
them anymore it's no longer used for
them to be involved with us
and then they come then you see you come
back next thing you know they're back
but you know what do you say to normally
when i was young i said get the [ __ ] out
of here
you wasn't bad but now you just watch
them and look at them that's it
plus i'll listen i have witnessed the
one person mike tyson is scared of
bread frenchy you can vouch for this his
mother-in-law
will whoop his [ __ ] ass well i
love him personally
she crazier than everybody at the table
yo mike yo mike you got the downest
most loyalist craziest brother-in-law i
ever
met i'm i'm more afraid of my wife you
know if a man a man
has a wife and he's not afraid of his
wife he's not living his life right
she's the greatest
he ain't living his life right if he's
not afraid of his wife yeah
you're right about that we got our man
fred fritchey in the building
he over here hi you know
telling people all the good things
you've done for people and [ __ ] friend
friendship man you know i'm gonna tell
you the things he's done for me when i
was trying to find my way in this
touring business
he lent me a helping hand when i started
managing gaming and uh
he was like probably doing putting
together 75 percent of my shows
out the gate of all my overseas um dates
per game and on top of that everybody he
was working with
i think he knew he was making his move
to do something bigger and better
and we'd get to that but everybody he
was working with he would personally put
me with him
and in this game people don't do that
you know what i mean they keep you away
they stay in the middle of it but for
maybe like two three years he put me
with everybody and next thing i know
[ __ ] i flew to dubai he braxton he flew
us to dubai
french picked us up in the drop top
rolls royce we go to french condo we on
the 158th floor
and i'm looking at these plans on the
wall and they say
[ __ ] mike tyson like what's going on
he tell me doing business with mike
and now he got it been two three years
he got 17
mike tyson fitness centers all through
europe
contracted to open up really talk about
one no we gotta have them talk talk
about when you first met me when we
first met him wasn't friendly what the
[ __ ]
who are you [ __ ]
hey first of all the first time i'm in
camera man i you guys got me by school
it's all love uh first time i met mike
crazy crazy story um so i used to work
for a
universal music right like uh i i worked
there for 2000 like 2003 2008
so i went back to europe so i made all
my contacts and everything
don robinson was the head of uh
international over there yeah yeah
told me yo man like you know we're about
to it's like a big crisis going on in
the u.s right now like you know
it's better that you make you move back
to europe and then you know we're going
to supply you artists and then you're
going to you know you
help you're going to help us and
everything so that's what i did
and uh long story short i was
controlling like probably
independently 60 to 70 of all the you
know exactly
urban shows over there so i was good i
received a phone call
2009 uh
from um icm
phone call from icm 2009.
and uh they told me hey uh
you know we we know that you know you
probably the only person can help us
like right now i was like all right
so what you need say uh we have a client
in italy he's stuck over there like you
know a promoter was supposed to come and
bring them some bring him some money or
some stuff like that
and uh it just vanished you know i was
like oh guys
you know tilting then like the story is
good right
and he's like all right but like this is
the trick like the promoter is i mean
the the
talent the client is very mad
the talent is very mad like they told me
some stuff like
apparently it was breaking stuff on in a
room and everything over there
i was like hell who's that
who's that like you come on man they
didn't want to tell me he said can you
help us like find something in italy
and i was like okay you're like but i
need to know who you are
who client is because you talk about
some guy who's mad yeah yeah
like you know uh the the promoter
vanished
he's breaking stuff on like you know in
the hotel room i'm like yo
who that crazy guy is like you know and
uh
it's like yo uh this mike tyson
i'm like you know jimmy i love you guys
but you know
i'm not so did you wear that i don't
need that money like that money
did you go to italy but you know they
called me back tony martin call me back
and all this they said they begged me
another server and say okay all right
i had they gave me like 48 hours long
story short i found like you know
gigs for for mike tyson like in 24 hours
like
dancing with the star over there we did
like you know uh
another show like completely night and
we're grinding because we need
money we need money right i got kids i
got two new kids
i got my kid with me here going [ __ ]
14-hour flights and we're like
yeah no money and then the promoter was
supposed to give mike like 30 or 40
000 i found like 180 or 200 000 like you
know
so made a contract with them and i was
like i'm good
he said you don't want any uh commission
said no i don't need commission you told
me like you know
he needs the money i respect mike i
never met in my life
you know it's the legend right there
like you know i'm good i don't need to
pro like the commission whatever blah
blah
all right so cool they called me the
next they say yo
they need you over there they want you
to drive over there i was like man come
on man
so they called me and say uh this is the
hotel and everything blah blah anyway
i met uh mike's wife who's my sister now
like you know i make
um my mother-in-law is my mom now
and uh milan milan was probably like
six months like six months and that's my
baby right now like you know now
like yeah so you know i met uh all of
them and we just clicked you know
and you probably don't know that but
like you know what it done for me is
like probably
way more than like i've been doing for
your family you know i mean it gave me
exactly you know you know
you already know my you know yeah i know
your background background so
you know that this thing is like you
know
modern i never had any contract with
mike no nothing
no like you know it's just love all
along i mean that's the best way to do
it was the best way to do it you know
was he
scary at first man like but the
the crazy thing is that like yeah of
course it was i was on medicine it
wasn't like it was opiate fact i would
need to [ __ ] have
pain kind of medicine back then i met
manic mac like i don't know if i can say
this but i think i was on cocaine
it was crazy but i mean something like
it's insomniac so we
i think he came to my room he can't
sleep he came to my room one day
and we had a conversation and i was like
damn like
he's deep because i never met like you
know oh now you're getting a chance to
let
me
meet bill you know so he's diving we're
talking about stuff he was talking about
stuff about me and my countries and
stuff like that i didn't even know this
guy
was like yo that's cool those don't know
frenchie it's from the congo
i don't know if y'all watched that
nephew the netflix series the beast of
all nations
you know what i'm saying as humble and
calm as he is right
um you had one side that was kind of
like the rebels
fighting the government and the
government fight another side and you
had these little kids
these little kids they was brainwashing
to be soldiers you know what i mean
you see them cutting them and putting
gun powder in their wounds like
trying to make them feel like they were
immortal and [ __ ] like that
right well a lot of people don't know is
frenchie was one of those little kids
you know i'm saying come from the congo
like for real you know i mean like
richie can't even go to jail in the
united states of america he got
diplomatic immunity because he survived
that [ __ ]
and he did what he had to do for his
country so for him to be as humble as he
is
right and and and and
i watched him i never forget we made
like 50 grand together or some [ __ ]
right
and uh we cut it up and frenchie
sent everything but about 500 bucks
back home towards his sister and his
mother and stuff i think one of his
somebody was in college at the time
french at the time
my brother was brother my brother was in
uh i played for my brothers like you
know
low school like you know law school yeah
you know what i'm saying so to see him
hustling not for himself but but but
to take care of his friend he got deep
roots like he got crazy ass uncles that
literally was controlled the military
over there in the congo so he could have
went
all kind of ways but somehow his ass
finally found himself
in [ __ ] america tied into everybody
and it's crazy whenever you mention
fritzy's name to anybody
it's the same response you know what i'm
saying
you know to the ladies i keep telling
y'all this man ain't married with no
children y'all
tripping y'all i'm almost married
oh my oh [ __ ] you been keeping the seat
girl back where's she
what's wrong oh
but this is an interesting guy right a
guy like me i could leave my wife a
woman for that long
period of time then come back you know
where he goes for periods
of time man you need um a traveling
partner
hey actually my my girl she's a a flight
attendant
well that's easy she's oh yeah perfect
yes sweet travel
free yeah she traveled a lot wow don't
tell me she
worked for emirates thanks for bringing
that out wow oh
[ __ ] thank you for illuminating yeah
for us yeah nah french you are brothers
i love fresh [ __ ]
oh god listen it's amazing dude you
didn't even want to come in here that's
like the best story
we've had no in the brotherhood it would
have taken me and mike tyson to get
french
that's true yeah i'm not a i'm not a i'm
not a camera guy like i like to be in
the background but you know
that's it i just had a promoter call me
other day
talking about man it's a [ __ ] guy
named frenchie i said hold on one second
before we continue this conversation
i clicked over and called frenchy
frenchie what'd i tell him so you got on
the phone
amen i was so embarrassed like for real
man like
this [ __ ] don't you ever address
him as some guy named friction
french he got the he probably the only
dude got the right to speak for me
he can speak for me like he can go in
there if i'm not there and he can speak
for me without me knowing he can
negotiate for me
because one thing i know what you're a
manager yeah
yeah music talent yeah i managed some
crazy [ __ ]
night for a period of time and sure was
probably one of my first teachers in
this game you know what i mean he
he showed me a lot she wanted she was a
dude that like
even though i don't get along with him
you know i mean we may argue fuss and
fight i still watch
make sure he's straight make sure you're
all right um but um
the game and i took the game french
watch me when
when they tried to ruin the game you
know when interscope tried to put him on
the shelf
and and tie him up for a couple years i
took hold of that
and made sure that didn't happen you
know we're still surviving we're still
doing great today
um i linked up with a birdman uh from
cash money
and um he uh him and slim gave me the
blessings to start cash money west
through that i i signed blueface so
blueface is our new talent he's doing
well right now
um um also got ray j
you know me and ray j go back yeah he
was here too
the sex tape and sexy cat eye and all
kind of crazy [ __ ] we've been through
that's still a little brother he's heavy
in the tech world right now oh yeah
and we i got a couple more acts i'm
signing so you know we getting over to a
lot i got a joint venture with nick
cannon right now
you know i went to [ __ ] uh to the
bronx right and i've seen these kids
running around i'm like yo what's up
with these kids diapers right they're
like oh yeah that's this diaper called
fitties it really doesn't absorb it's
just there to catch the
you know the feces and [ __ ] right so you
know
it kind of like bothered me a little bit
right so i started doing my research on
on diapers right
so i ran into these females at the uh
cheerleading situation you know my
daughter
does a traveling cheerleading right
she's like a level five flyer
she does all that stuff right so i'm
talking to the ladies they talk about a
feminine product called cherish that you
got to order over internet you can't buy
in the store
and they start talking about um um
fabroids and thyroids and all kinds of
stuff because of the kickback
um right but this cherished material
absorbs everything
so i started doing my research and i had
the people create a diaper
for me so right so the diaper now has a
14-hour absorbent
so i was doing a lot of business with
nick cannon at the time and uh
i was trying to come up with a name for
the diaper like what could i call the
diaper right
so i did a license deal with nick cannon
i called the diaper incredible
it's incredible diapers right so now i'm
like okay well
i want to create a diaper for the hood
that's just as good if not better as
huggies and pampers for the
you know the people that don't have all
that money so yes i was able to get the
cost down
for a pack of 20 for 7.77
i got a contract with the bodega
association you know i mean throughout
uh
um jersey connecticut and new york so
i'll start promoting over there
we're on the last phases of testing um
bv labs over here europe
already passed with flying color so when
it it's done doing this thing over here
then
we'll launch that tell me this that's
great this is awesome tell me about it
hey this this isn't i had a friend that
did they had beautiful diapers
awesome diapers and he said mike um put
this in the store with your friends to
ask them where they put this in the
store and so i you know
i want to help somebody grab this up and
see you and put this in your store
he said mike i can't because i have a
contract with um pampers
what tell me about that i said tell me
about that i have um
i have a legal contact um contract i
can't um
carry nobody else's diapers but theirs
exactly my contract oh so you know about
that so
i said wow so i said um i never knew
anything i'm young i'm 21 i'm
just you know so i'm thinking like [ __ ]
that's my friend
i look at the the godfather put this on
your shelf yeah yeah yeah i don't know
[ __ ] i don't know [ __ ] with pampers i
don't know i don't know so he explains
it to me said no mike i can't
just put it no i can't because i gotta
sell this i'm gonna get in trouble if i
don't if i put anything else on my shelf
i said [ __ ]
and so that's what i want to tell you
how are you able to do that
see what i did was
what i want to do is not just sell the
diapers
right so i went to new york because as
you understand new york
like we got liquor stores they have
bodegas yes potatoes
and the bodegas are ran by bodega
association
you understand what i'm saying and then
these bodegas it's a lot of the smaller
products because the area is just like
it's like
zero income to maybe twenty thirty
thousand but they go to 24 hours 24
hours so
it's like 60 000 bodegas throughout the
tri-state
so what i'm going to do is
once we launch these diapers right then
you'll
look up and i'm going to send um the
testing the eye
visual testing into the schools right
compliments of incredible diapers
a lot of these kids are failing because
not because they can't read they can't
see
they just don't know it yeah when you're
in these low-income areas man people are
trying to survive people are waking up
every day
making sure it's food on the table it's
water it's clothes on their back they
really don't have time
to deal with those little intricate
things you know i mean
as far as a jacket giveaway we want to
sponsor kids
to get them to college i i even want to
i even what i'm
definitely going to do like my part of
my marketing plan we all remember willy
wonka and the chocolate yeah
right the golden ticket right so i got
this thing i created called the golden
diaper
so every quarter if you get that packet
with the golden diaper
the first time it may be a ten thousand
dollar cash prize the next time
we may step in and pay your rent up for
12 months
next time we'll give you a thousand
dollar gift card to go
grocery shopping for 12 months these are
things that i knew when i was younger my
mother
knew her rent was paid up for 12 months
or she had a thousand dollars
card to go shopping for the next 12
months i guarantee you it's going to be
paid
like this yeah if you get that gold and
if you get that pack
yeah then we're going to come right
where you at we're going to cover your
rent for the next 12. that's what the
price is
the price is 10 000 we're going to give
you that if it's a new car we're going
to give you that
if if it's the family we send a family
on a big mike as you know we all know
you got families in the ghetto brother
that if you told them they had
five first class tickets to goddamn
london they wouldn't even know how to go
to the airport
and get the ticket so i want to be able
to send a family
someplace hey listen i right now don't
know how to do that
that's crazy all right right now if you
were to give me some money if i had some
money or a credit card he said go get a
ticket
i wouldn't know the first time i would
just know i need a ticket but i wouldn't
know how to do it what type of ticket
you need what would you want to attend
i wouldn't know what i want to know i
wouldn't know where to take it course
so right now i don't know the [ __ ]
ticket quest from here to vegas yeah so
what i want to do
is not is i want to i want to make
incredible diapers
in my life other than immunity not just
we making profit off of them
i want people when they see that
incredible thing to say oh [ __ ]
they gave my kids a a grant to go to
school they
you know i want to go to the local
schools and upgrade the book system
bring the ipod system you know bring
that something then i want to sit there
two three years i'm not gonna
i can go to walmart i can go anywhere i
want to go but i want to sit here in
these communities
you know i mean help let's let's go
rebuild a house with somebody you know
what i mean let's go see who's roofs are
leaking or who
you know anything that's going on had
that hotline
you know what i mean i want to create a
um incredible anti-bullying system to
where a person could literally
go on the internet and say this kid
leaving this school is getting so
prepared for that to happen right now
right now you prepared to go and
clean up clean up clean out i mean we
got to start a
[ __ ] abandoned lot yeah we got to
start exactly because see mike
coming into it it's not really more
profit for me right
because what's going to happen with me
is after two three years
these bigger companies see what i'm
doing they see the volume on moving
right now you know how many people in
the tri-state the bigger company's gonna
say well [ __ ]
he's operating at a lower cost and he's
moving
this independent right they're gonna
come anyway and help me make the
situation bigger
so right now it's really to give back to
the people like we may not realize it
because we as babies we can't talk
but you know what that means for that
baby not to experience a diaper rash
my product we can pour a a liter of
ginger ale in there and mush it against
your face and you won't feel nothing
wow 14-hour absorbent awesome man you
know what i'm saying so you know i'm
doing that
um it's a few other things we're doing
i'm about to bring back the
mike might remember remember the og
quick and split burger stands
[ __ ] no you're my quickest players
i just got with the family you know
their parents had passed away and they
went
to the wayside so they wanted me to help
them bring that back so i'm gonna help
them bring that dream
you know wake that dream back up and
continue doing a lot of music
and um cross-branding and you know
helping the community and um
you know shout out to my team you know
what i mean out here in greater la if
you realize french you watched us do it
in the last 10 years you have seen
minimum gang violence
in the hip-hop community you know what i
mean
mike you remember [ __ ] couldn't
go to no clubs and it's a blood-driven
thing without the crypt showing up
and vice versa but you know we created a
table
of bloods and crypts to where within
this music industry that when it's a
problem
it comes to the table and then we deal
with it the right way it's supposed to
be dealt with
it was at one point in time snoop and
game couldn't even get insurance to even
going buildings out here because
the violence you know what i mean so you
know uh wacko out of west side par route
compton big you out to roll the 60s
bob by the carver park blue out of long
beach insane
yeah you know top dog tde out of bounty
hunters
you know the list goes on and on there's
about 10 of us d carter 8 9 east coast
that really sit at this table and we we
helped keep people did you know took it
no i didn't know tooky personally but
definitely knew up to toki was in prison
you know tooky
the penitentiary system [ __ ] late 70s
and early 80s or some [ __ ]
do you feel like um nipsey's death
brought those two groups together
even more well how do you not i mean i
know i know that any
i know the politics of that right yeah
and i gotta set the record straight
i feel like nipsey's death
definitely um started the conversation
but what ignited that movement was a guy
named big u they called him draws
rolling 60s and nipsey was from rolling
60s
and it really took his voice because it
was him that
summons everybody to show up on chris
sean slauson it just didn't happen
because of nipsey's death
because nipsey's death was internal a
rolling 60 kill
rolling 60. so it took big you a lot of
people don't know he has a company
called developing options
for the last 10 years he's been having
contracts with the city
to um help um control the gang violence
he's been having it down by 30 40
percent in that crenshaw area which is
some serious significant right you know
what i mean so you know uh
rest in peace and nipsey hustle but his
his death
definitely ignited the conversation but
big u's been promoting pushing this for
the last 10 years so
it really kind of like woke people up
yeah because it was an internal thing
like oh roller 60 killed a rolling 60
but big you took it upon itself not to
just shed the light on the rolling 60s
just say
oh man feel sorry for us he said you
know what let's take my little homeboy
death
a genocide that happened within our
tribe and you know what
let's bring all of us together and
that's what was big about that yeah
black where are you based new york or
los angeles
when did you first meet mike i first met
mike personally about a year ago
um at his [ __ ] oh really that is
comedy
i went there i went out there to meet
him i met his mother-in-law frenchie
brought me out
and i'm telling myself okay i got to see
mike do comedy first you're telling me
watch it on the internet i didn't want
to watch [ __ ] on the internet
i'm like it's no [ __ ] way mike
tyson's first first of all
i didn't want to put them together
because you know why it's like dynamite
not because french you know
you got the mentality of two people that
when it comes down to it
we can be very irrational if that's what
we want to be it's hard to stop
that that trade will come but i said
here and i'm like
i'm laughing and the reason why i'm
laughing because mike
is so comfortable with talking about
himself
see most comedians going and they talk
about other people he's
talking about himself and you didn't
realize how
[ __ ] up [ __ ] it got for mike mike
talking about it
you know he started saying oh man i was
in the cage fight i'm like
no [ __ ] i remember that [ __ ] remember
the tabloids report mike tyson's in the
cage like
they were saying all kind of crazy [ __ ]
right but to hear him get up there
and actually talk about himself then he
had these clips going on behind him
oh man i don't know what the [ __ ] i was
thinking right you know what i'm saying
like so
to see that and to be able to see a man
of his statute come from where he come
from
to have that sense of humor and to
embrace whatever gift brother they got a
picture of me that using my [ __ ] with me
i didn't even know i i got cocaine all
over my nose
[ __ ] somebody took a picture of me
i got cocaine white my [ __ ] lips and
white i'm thinking i don't see and then
people looking they took a picture
and i see it oh [ __ ] oh no i thought i
was going to jail for some reason i
didn't know how to
[ __ ] okay the whole world seemed on my
coast you know
what i'm saying i'm the cocaine he let
people know where i came from and where
i've been they come from
i come from a small city outside of los
angeles city called pacquiao
so everybody in the city of baquin was
[ __ ] mike tyson fans
everybody thought it was mike tyson
everybody started boxing all of a sudden
it was [ __ ]
uh punching bags hanging from the trees
in the backyard
it was all mike tyson driven you know
what i mean so it's like
you know and be able to years later to
go to i've been to the penitentiary i
was the first mine in state of
california they sent me to prison at 16
years old i was in solidar state
penitentiary so to go through all that
survive all these gang wars all these
attempts on my life
when you inside that what they do did
they talk to you about what's the what's
the [ __ ] with themselves
brothers well that guy keep it real
george jackson they talk about that
everybody listen i'ma keep it real
anybody
who'd been to solid dab when it was
solid at back in those days late 80s
early 90s right
i don't give a [ __ ] how tough you are
and at this point i thought i was
invincible
listen when the judge said i was a minor
i said well
cya won't accept you i don't know what
to do with you if i give you a 10 year
reduction
from 17 years or 7 years will you sign
waiver paper so i can send you to state
prison to a men's facility
i hurried up and signed them i didn't
give a [ __ ] frenchie that's that picture
i post up
on instagram so i was i felt like i was
ready for it let me tell you something
when you pull up in them solid that
gates and this whack 100 telling you
this [ __ ]
and you see them gun towers them old
prison cards with a billy club they
ain't even
black [ __ ] is chrome right
every gangsta thug says
what the [ __ ] did i just get myself into
then you go on the intake and you got
like four or five tears of these little
windows everybody looking at you
now it's time to hit the yard and when i
tell you up there you got the north
daniels
which get into it with the surrenos you
got the bay area card with clicks with
the bloods you got the [ __ ] cards you
got the san diego card then you got the
pie size which we call
the mexicans from mexico who don't
really speak english then you got the
woods
the white boys call themselves woods in
there
then you got the nlrs outside of the
woods the nazi lowriders then you got
the bgf
you got the vanguard then you got the
muslims then you got the christians
then you got the homosexual community
and everything
everybody's capable of killing you
everybody
everybody's capable of killing but in
that prison in that prison
is where i can honestly say i
stopped gang banging me and i stopped
hating the [ __ ]
because something happened to me in that
prison that that made me wake up it was
a war going on between the blacks and
hispanics
and um you know we was all to come out
to the yard and
all the blacks was together against the
hispanics at this time the sudanese the
south side
hispanics had united they wasn't beefing
with each other no more
they called the shot that we all come
together and our mission is to get rid
of everything black
so we were still going at each other
crips and bloods while they all came
together
already outnumbered this 341 right so i
was working in the kitchen at the time
and i stole i remember
when they had a bread rack then rods so
i broke down the rods like 13 14 rods
and i snuck them back and i passed them
out
right all bloods so we come out to the
yard we doing our thing some people go
to the hole some people make it back to
the yard right
so maybe two three days later after this
situation they come to my cell and say
jones roll it up before that on the yard
it's a dude named three finger louie
from harlem crypt
who called my name it was a mexican dude
had me for my blind side probably gonna
take my life
so three finger louis saved my life for
doing the war so let's establish that
two days later i'll make it back to the
cell they say we got to roll it up i
said for what reason
they said well we heard you provided
weapons for the war
so i'm thinking to myself who's my enemy
the crypt that saved my life
or one of these bloods they told them
because they the only ones i gave knives
to
so from that day forward i never asked
nobody where they was from
if i see you i approached you as a man
as a black man if you wanted the gang
bang [ __ ] it i was real versus that we
could do that
but i started to see life different you
know what i mean and and that that was
one of the major changes frenchie's been
around me he knows my politics i can
have
i could be my myself with 10 of my [ __ ]
partners and you would never know it
because i see because the only reason
why we're from where we're from because
our mother our grandmother our father
raised up over
raised us over there nobody took a test
to say okay
because of your test results you from
hoover are you from compton are you from
watts are you a [ __ ] or you're a blood
are you a pyruvate
it's just that's what he was raised up
as and gangs really was formed to
protect the black communities and then
it just went to where it went to
it's been that we were white you've been
like way since the beginning of tribal
yeah it's just gang's been it's
the first crew the first people that
came together
prehistoric to help each other yeah yeah
so it's always been that but you know
i'm happy to survive and i'm happy to be
here to uh
teach the people coming up under me you
know what i mean
something different than the hatred i
grew up on because a lot of these kids
is gang-banging
and they don't even know why they
dislike the people across the street
they just know the people said don't
like them
you know i'm like just [ __ ] a lot of
these wars start of a [ __ ] a pair of
shoes a jacket
you know a female some [ __ ] that had
really nothing to do with the streets
but
because the dude it happened would have
been the dude calling the shots
that's just where it went you know what
i mean this word politics
is defined as something totally
different when you when you're in the
ghetto mike you know that it's like a
this principle thing is people in jail
right now because they killed the
[ __ ] over five out of dice game
because of the principle
that you did that to me and people was
watching
you know what i mean it's really an act
of craziness but we we we just won't say
that
but it's been like again i'm talking
about gangs
black gangs and that most latino there's
been the only gangs that have been
caught in that
vicious cycle where they can never get
out of the gang mostly when you see the
irish gangs attack
these guys have been killed at the heavy
and gangs when they were 10 13 year old
they came up from the ghetto
and then they went to school they made
it somebody mentored them eventually
they got all these marks off their
record now they're the governor they're
the mayor yeah that's right the
president
and once they were gangs yeah you know
what i mean
that's real even the harvard league the
yale oxford they have their gangs
it's just who it is it's who we are as
nature we we're gonna die alone we're
gonna
deal with god and face him alone but in
life we have to live
together well that's real that's
definitely you definitely have to do it
because i you know i've learned and
experienced so much being able to mix
with
other cultures like being able to go to
new york you know and go up to to harlem
with kay slay
you know go up to the bronx you know
with pistol peter go down there
to brooklyn you know with uncle murder
or or you know down to sugar hill
uncle murder is the man yeah well you
know with my bpe people
just to be able to you know go to
brooklyn was special drop in atlanta
with p and my qc team or
you know drop in in the texas you know
what i mean
and you know watch our man down in
houston do his thing what's the homie
name um
banner no kill might know that the
brother that does all the help the flood
victims and all that rap he rapped too
that button b
right no that bomb beat other brothers
solid brother um
trade the truth go down there will trade
to see the things he's doing
even slim tug yeah and be able to go to
miami and
and and and feel the embrace of
headliner mike down and all these people
was like
to be able to come from where i come
from if you experience these different
things these different cultures
um it's a blessing but it also it's also
it also something you got to learn to
control
you know i'm like i've been in moscow i
think the most craziest [ __ ] i did was
in moscow
moscow's the craziest place no obviously
crazy the
it made me realize what no it made you
realize everybody in my school has a
mental problem
we do the show somebody book us for
after party right
we out there with game on our on our on
our tour right
so we get to moscow when you get to the
hotels like a [ __ ] airport you got to
run your luggage through this
to the scanner right so we do the show
we go to after party
we go like two stories down on the
ground or some [ __ ] and it's like some
bottle type
[ __ ] you like beds and all kinds of [ __ ]
so we're in the vip i know how to treat
you in my face i figured we'd do our
hour
and we get out of here right so
somewhere in there i guess the dude
tells the promoter
that we supposed to do a [ __ ]
performance i said no we we're just here
to host and be here we're not performing
man just before him for our
you know games boy says i gotta arrest
him right but dude
i said matter of fact called my ground
up now this is where
and mike understands this [ __ ] when you
dealing with us
over here bro no matter where we at it's
just gonna be what it's gonna be dude
tells me
[ __ ] that nobody going nowhere until you
do the
show you're in moscow he said some crazy
[ __ ] some crazy [ __ ] some crazy [ __ ]
only i forgot i was in moscow
so the minute he said the minute he said
i broke his mother i i get off on him
i think like we in [ __ ] south
central l.a and the homies outside
we two stories down the ground he's in
control of i don't know how to get out
the
bill so when i get off on funny my whole
band is all
ex-convicts but one dude [ __ ] ep
everybody else's ex-convicts been to the
feds and everything
yeah we all fighting in [ __ ] moscow
on the brothel
under the under the ground so what
listen
so this i never told nobody this but i'm
gonna keep it real says mike show right
so we make it out of there we get the
driver we get back but you know those
[ __ ] hotels are in moscow
the rooms are like the windows is like
right on the street you can't book an
early flight
because the airport is closed you just
thought i was [ __ ] michael max
peeking out that window all night
only i didn't have nothing but a broom
because we had no firearms
i'm nervous as a [ __ ] i'll fly
left at 12 i told the ground to be there
at
6 8 and you know russia they rolling
crews hey listen bro
hey listen shout out to moscow for not
coming to kill my punk ass
i don't apologize for the right hook i
did what i had to do with my impulse
but shout out to moscow for not coming
to get me because i thought they was
coming together
hey man that's really insane bro for
real i swear bro
amazing i was like that night i said you
know you got a [ __ ] problem
you're in moscow hey bro i mean you were
on
impulse yeah you know yeah i didn't know
how to receive that as a man
[ __ ] that you ain't going nowhere
i didn't know how to hear that mike you
know what mike you didn't have a few
situations
let me tell you this thing i'm in moscow
right i'm with a friend
and so um this guy that i met and um
was doing a trip i was in um turkey at
the formula once i met a guy and he said
i'm gonna have somebody set you up me
hit you up when i get tomorrow so i get
to moscow
and these guys come in limousines right
me and my friend they put us in the car
and it's weird they don't talk to us
they take and they drive us to this big
beautiful men's mansion this is
beautiful you know
you go in there it's marbles guys this
beautiful big match around 40 000 square
feet just beautiful
and then we're in there he puts it in
the house and there's me
and then there's these beautiful girls
my friend said let's go back to um
the boat right and so
the girl the one she doesn't know i
don't want to go with them
right so the guy grabs her the guy that
in the car
when he told him to don't go with him
and she said no i don't want to so the
guy grabs and puts her face
and smashes her face in the car and
we're in the car and this is the one
and the face goes boom
don't worry you don't have to do nothing
we just want to get out of here from
these guys you know
these guys drop us off man holy
[ __ ] hey yo look i swear wow
yeah it's a mic it's a different roomy
ass
like you because when i go there right
one day i left my hotel room without
telling anybody and i went down red
square i wanted to take some pictures of
red square
and some of the pictures where um
creator great was there executing his
friend you know those
things they're there those monuments to
there yeah and then when that the
security all
drove up and caught up on with shotguns
with machine guns all around me
don't ever leave without us i'm like
real aggressive like their calm is
aggressive just the way they talk
listen they scared people because i
didn't want to go out with them because
people see me with these guys with guns
they're scared the girls were scared
everybody would i said i can't hang out
with you guys
no way it's really crazy it's creepy if
you're a famous person in moscow and you
have a lot of money
you walk around with um armed guards
well somebody will kidnap you
no doubt about it yeah yeah no doubt
about it i looked the other day i had to
go to [ __ ] mexico rosarito beach and
take game down yeah that's scary too
you know i did some what we call some
bust ass [ __ ] but i don't give a [ __ ]
whack 100 gonna keep it 100.
i told the promoter listen i need police
escort from [ __ ] tj to rosarita beach
that [ __ ] is out
right i already got my ground they from
[ __ ] hollywood they got the insurance
survivors in there
right so what scared me when my ground
showed up no suits
they got regular boots on and jeans and
wrinkles i said what the [ __ ] you doing
oh no we don't want them to know we're
the drivers or the spinners right
so we down at 11 30 at night so here we
go we're going from
tijuana to rosarito scary stuff the
[ __ ] cop
you know police down there just said
corrupt like a [ __ ]
how we police so we get in there right
we get the job done
immediately spinning out we get back in
the sprinters just when [ __ ] get [ __ ]
up
we get about 12 miles out from the
border
and the police escorts makes a right and
disappears on us
oh [ __ ] so you know what i'm thinking
these [ __ ] know we got paid
it's going down um right so i tell my
driver i said look don't say no don't
let nobody know we lost just try to
follow
the [ __ ] map but his map keeps
buffering
because we're in mexico right they
already did a trick on us because when
we
supposed to have your passport right
when we came in they
didn't scan nobody's passport you know
what that means there's no record of us
being here
you understand what i'm saying now they
gonna check your passport when you get
to the [ __ ] border coming back
in case they want to hold your ass or
extort you so i tell everybody keep
80 to 100 bucks in your pocket no jury
that way when they go down just tap the
pocket let them get what they gonna
get and get on so i was scared as a
[ __ ] daddy french we didn't make
it out of there till like 3 30 in the
morning what happened
the driver the driver found a taxicab
taxi and said i'll pay you if you can
get us to the border
see when the police escort left us i
said oh [ __ ] why did they leave
yo listen man that's a [ __ ] i
know it's not the right way when i'm in
situations i just start freaking the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] hit me
[Music]
right
can i light this up yeah there's some
good stuff yeah first of all [ __ ] that
you asking all these questions
yeah brother [ __ ] what's up with you
guys
these tattoos with these crazy names i
can't pronounce
i don't know who the [ __ ] are you
explain that tell us who you are man
you know what i'm from the five seven
and under crew so you know
you from the top tall dude who the [ __ ]
are you the tall dude
what is that tattoo man what does that
[ __ ] say this
yeah this says v2 alamen profatum which
means
sacrifice for destiny
sacrifice for destiny that action could
be
determined all kind of ways we're gonna
let that go
you tell us who the [ __ ] are you where
did you come from
and how did you end up sitting here
mike tyson good question great questions
go ahead dude
well i'm evan i played pro football
gotcha
six years jags and the bears uh i was
drafted in 2009
39th overall born in new york city
moved to l.a when i was 10 grew up in
l.a
went to high school tell us about your
grandma too my grandmother's
estelle parsons she's an academy
award-winning actress for
one for best supporting actress and
bonnie and clyde and
oh [ __ ] 19 60
with fate done away right yeah
i retired from football in 2014. i
started writing
and talking about my experience with
injuries and all the pills and the
opiates
and how cannabis had been such a
positive
pain relievered throughout my football
career
[ __ ] man do they test for marijuana in
india
yeah oh [ __ ] so even though it helps
it's illegal you still
can't got you that's what we're trying
to explain talk more please
so i got out of the league i started
talking about
the positive benefits of cannabis for
football players or
any athletes who experience a lot of
injuries or brain trauma
got you this has become my my path you
know speaking this truth about how
cannabis
helped me deal with all the concussions
and the surgeries i had
you know while the pills made me feel
insane cannabis really helped me recover
and sleep
and so i meet mike i help him put on
this summit
i bring in a bunch of athletes nba nfl
uh ufc guys mike mike and i host it
and they're like hey man well we like
your energy we dig your vibe we'd like
you to come here we don't know what
you're gonna do yet but
just come be a part of it let me ask you
a question yeah that movie
i know was it will smith but somebody
was a movie about football players
concussions man concussion yeah how how
true
what did you see that movie yeah man
that's the that's
that's the number one problem with
football right now you know is
concussions and the cte
chronic traumatic encephalopathy which
is what
happens you basically end up early onset
alzheimer's or dementia so guys who are
in their 40s are being diagnosed with
alzheimer's
guys that i know were in late 30's yeah
because of all the head-to-head contact
and so what they
found in cannabis our federal government
has a patent on cannabinoids
as neuroprotectants and antioxidants
that means they've seen in scientific
studies that this [ __ ] helps protect the
brain
and so for me i used to smoke weed
before playing football games
you know what's [ __ ] up bro is at what
point in time did the government
consider marijuana which is a natural
herb illegal
what is it
god placed it here for us for the
healing of the body
yeah you understand what i'm saying that
doesn't even know god placed so many
other plants but this isn't here for a
reason yeah this is not it's not like
coke you know cocaine came from the
poppies in his distance that
is this then we taking to do this and
then i surround yeah this is some [ __ ]
grows out of the ground
out of the ground and from talking to
everybody i talk to
is like it helps them it's like yeah you
know what i mean so
why why would they have even could what
made them consider
marijuana illegal this is where you get
into conspiracy
because black people did it got you they
wanna it's one it's another
yeah well we thought it was funny when
we watched cheech and chong yeah
yeah it was humorous i know well that's
sort of the
you know there's been so much propaganda
in 1937
harry henry anslinger and
william randolph hearst just launched
this huge propaganda campaign to
talk about how mexicans and blacks were
smoking weed
going crazy and raping white women yeah
they're hippies
well then in the 60s nixon took it upon
himself to attack
the two groups that were most
detrimental to his presidency which were
the hippies the counter culture movement
and the blacks
so he went after the black panthers and
he went after the hippies
and that's all documented by his people
they stopped
giving me some cbd water yeah yeah
that's good
they were telling me they were like it
wasn't because you know i don't smoke or
nothing right so i'm like yo
like nah it's not marijuana yeah right
yeah it's the non-psychoactive part yeah
exact thc
you know in science the funny thing is
man science keeps
proving more and more how beneficial
cannabis is for us guys you know what he
is that's why
so much on the verge of becoming you
know exactly
yeah i'm the only thing they working on
now is the feds want to see how they go
on taxes like prohibition once they can
tax it
i'm going to tell you what's going to
happen i see it coming the tobacco
industry because they already got
yeah [ __ ] oh they're all ready
they're raised
yes they got everything it takes to turn
around and mass produce
this [ __ ] you know what i mean so and
when that happens hey brother
we beat you we got some cbd tobacco now
too
yeah see what i'm saying yeah that's
crazy damn it's crazy
we have that we have that they're mine
just showed me some crazy [ __ ] i don't
know when it's coming in the near future
but he got this
big ass resort yes and palm springs
no longer you got to go out there for
coachella and
smell good god damn day so whack on that
point man as a guy
coming into this as a former athlete you
know a guy who looked up to mike i used
to watch mike's knockout tapes before
[ __ ] night before games to get jacked
up
you know to come into a situation where
i've got you know
the epitome the ultimate warrior of all
time
who i can stand with and speak this
truth
and we could do this together and he's
got he's doing it the right way man
you know with the ranch and i mean i'm
not beating nobody i'm not beating no
tax people everything
this is legit as [ __ ] man so it was a
great opportunity for me and i just feel
blessed to be here and i get to
interview you know this guy's doing this
game right now they're beating taxes
like a month but they're gonna get
caught up with all kind of [ __ ] they're
all they're getting money but they're
gonna get caught up yeah exactly you
know i mean
longevity equals success so you gotta do
it right the longer you can do something
most
chances you gotta be in success with it
yeah definitely you're right
i just i'm just thankful i'm thankful to
be able to sit down
with people like mike and french and
yourself you know what i mean to where
you guys are giving me this platform
because millions and millions of people
gonna watch this
because a lot of people think you know i
[ __ ] around a lot on social media that's
not really
the stuff oh i'm glad you said that
that's not really
the whole time what was the deal man you
keep fighting on who you fighting with
who are you fighting man i mean you're
fighting with the black ones
he was invisible right but you know what
it is a lot of people go to church
is supposed to be here today a lot of
people are [ __ ] with my name
they go to [ __ ] with my name and like
get followers like i think trek that's
what it was
trench got mad because i addressed some
tupac [ __ ] right
and and and i understand the whole tupac
area so i stand on him
don't get it [ __ ] up i'm a tupac fan
of his music
right i just feel like certain things
like for instance if i'm in
if i'm in new york right and i'm with a
bunch of guys from brooklyn
and i'm in new york and i'm with 20 guys
from brooklyn
and they see this dude or we see this
dude that these dudes don't get along
with right
i'm not gonna be the one to initiate
that because this is not my jungle
and he's not my politics i'ma roll with
my team whatever they do i'ma ride with
them
but i'm not gonna initiate it because i
don't know the politics
behind what can happen with this right
and i'll say that to say this
i think tupac was so real
about what he wanted to do in some
situations
he overdid it right and and i'm gonna
speak this because mike understands this
because this is one of the knights of
his fights
it was better decision making if two it
was it was 30 power rules there
and it was an issue with a coptin [ __ ]
if tupac
would allow those power rules you had
everything from sugar
to butchery everybody was dead i can
call that shot
right so they're familiar with who this
guy is right but you know what they know
they in
a hotel sugar's on [ __ ] nine-year
joint suspension
you know what i'm saying right now any
trouble he get he's going for nothing
film kicking somebody in the head all
this [ __ ] right so
trying to that decision you know to kick
that fight off right i stand behind this
was on the decision of those power rules
and the homies
see what happens is once tupac took
flight the homies ain't got no choice
but to take flight
right because they would him right now
this is probably a decision they
wouldn't have made
now because of that decision a lot of
[ __ ] got [ __ ] up
he lost his life suge ended up going for
five six years he lost his company
behind this [ __ ]
a lot of families were affected the
hip-hop community was affected
so i feel like that was a point in time
to where
and tupac was young 24 25 at the time
that was that was a point in time where
i feel like
as an individual because that was no rap
[ __ ]
he overstepped his boundaries you know
what i mean was he tied to any gang
well he was he was signed to death row
and and he was he started to associate
and feel like heavy with the power rules
with my power rules
you know what i'm saying and that and
that's another thing it's like
i'm always going to respect the guy that
wherever they go they they're who they
are
he was an entertainer bro he was good at
what he did whether it was film whether
it was
he's an intellect yeah
and i think what happens with the fans
even the fans that don't know him wasn't
even alive when he was alive
they take his history and they they [ __ ]
it up
all tupac shot at the police too [ __ ]
tell yourself i shot at some white dudes
i was
beating up a brother i didn't know they
was off duty police i later found out
because for you to say that you really
[ __ ] with his legacy of who he was
who he stood for
now you're saying tupac is black to run
around shooting the police
and that really wasn't the case let's
give it man credit for the things he
really did
you know what i mean yeah the rape
situation there was other politics
caught up in that
and that really wasn't that really
wasn't what that was you know i mean i
was some whole other set up [ __ ] and
he was he was a victim of that situation
but once again i surrounded yourself
with with the wrong people
at the you know at those times but
people miscarried i'm a tupac
fan i know half is music by heart i
wrapped it in the whole
solitary confinement i worked out to a
little way so i think trench
when the movie came out i made a comment
about the movie the recent one yeah
and i was i was a lot of people don't
know frenchie noticed that movie was
delayed
because they couldn't get that music
clear see uh a death row sold to death
row catalog to e1
music which i have strong relationships
to a lot of business in that building
two of my artists are signing that
building right now i've been there ten
years
ray j's hit sexy kind of the game the
documentary two all that came out of e1
so i made the phone call from benny
boone and um in lt
2e1 to help speed up that process to get
their music cleared it was other things
they had to do but that was a major part
of it right because i had seen the
preview and in that preview
it was some things in there that they
depicted you know where his mom
as far as when she was getting hided i
had a conversation with with the people
and like
maybe we need to tone that [ __ ] down
right but i knew
me talking [ __ ] about the movie
was going to drive people to watching
the movie
people are so slow that the day of the
movie frenchie would i go buy a thousand
tickets a game away
of course like i went myself and bought
a thousand tickets from the box
and took them to barber shops and said
if you come get your haircut this
barbershop you get a free ticket
so people don't it doesn't dawn that you
know i'm i'm kind of like
people saying you're not a tupac fan
yeah they say i'm a tupac hater
what is it uh tupac was with my wife
before i was
you know i mean but these are fans
saying crazy [ __ ] so
trench instead of doing his homework
spoke out of turn i didn't know it
i had no idea until somebody told me the
things he was saying
and once i heard i wasn't looking for
him because they told me he was in la so
i went to all the clubs all the places
he goes
and i was letting him know i'm looking
for you because i was real upset because
i didn't know the dude
and had nothing problems what to do but
he was saying some disrespectful [ __ ]
so i just what did he say he said all
connie made a [ __ ] song a dis song
all kind of [ __ ]
so i got a preaching i'm not i let him
know because they tell me go to this
spot
and eagle wood called the gs sports club
gs
is live y'all every night l.a stop by
the gs sports lounge
it's real cool food everything
entertainment so i went over there
looking for him because they said he's
there every night
so the owner called called him he said
yo wax here looking for you by himself
nobody with him
he wants to talk to you about this [ __ ]
you've been saying on the internet just
like that just like that
so dude i stayed waited 30 minutes an
hour they said yo he's at a spot in
hollywood
i stream on the hollywood at this time
big you
everybody in this in the streets trying
to catch me before i catch him
they like whacked him flew out the
[ __ ] header we got to catch
this [ __ ] because they know
telling what he gonna do when he so i've
never seen him
and never ran into him and i started
getting the phone calls the next day
people called me the homies from the boo
y'all tried
you know everybody calling me you know
like whack you gotta let it go so i
listen i was a man of my word i let it
go
but you know whack you know i i i i be
in places
you know i get backstage i'm a red
carpet i'm at you know the weirdest
places
and i just hope you hold on to what it
was
because we definitely got to put some
closure today and listen i promise you
i promise you i'm not a bully i i'm not
into torturing [ __ ] no more so
i'm gonna make it fast you know what i'm
saying tell us about torturing man i'm
gonna make it fast
i'm gonna because i always got this
thing in my head and i want to outdo
tyson
and that's why when i get my fights i'm
like tyson did some [ __ ] in like
seven seconds so i'm trying to make it
like 3.8
it'll be real fast my brother i promise
you
like don't i don't give [ __ ] where we at
barbra streisand
whatever it is don't act like you didn't
say what you said
don't act like you didn't say what you
said because it's
definitely going to be a dress this is
the
[ __ ] yo frenchy you didn't been with me
dozens of places
i don't want to hit nobody i don't
know hey listen basically
yo but mike listen how long have you
been doing this cannabis thing
for four years huh four years
yo can you tell these people about what
you just showed me he just showed me
some
crazy um the first of its kind
state-of-the-art
cannabis friendly um resort the ranch
waterfall a wave pool basketball race
runs
concert halls tranquility horseback ride
i mean yo you name it yeah it's crazy
it's dope i don't even smoke weed and
i'm going
me and the whole family i might even
bring the pastor oh yeah you know what
i'm saying the bastard would love it we
have pastors there as well because every
now and then people want to get married
so they get married there's also you
know what i'm saying
and you know what in the chapel when the
first church
opens that allows you to smoke weed
during the goddamn
service everybody gonna lose members
hey listen um a hundred years from now
this world's gonna be totally different
totally different definitely and i'm
trying to you know stay living you know
once we we go to the afterlife but you
know i want my name to be out here tyson
what you mean your name would you want
your name to be out here
on another branch yeah you already mike
tyson yeah
yeah i never think about that guy you
know i gotta get away from the guy with
this guy now
i ain't gonna lie i probably shouldn't
say that but frenchy let me scoot over a
little bit
you know you're a commitment every time
he totally is man every time i find
myself
looking at a [ __ ] ear i think
about mike tyson
oh
[ __ ] that what the [ __ ] because i
watched that clip i'm like okay
pigeons don't lock up out of nowhere it
was just
what the [ __ ] it was do you remember
did you say [ __ ] this what i'm gonna
do or did you
black out and then it happened and then
like no i just [ __ ] last night
remember
this [ __ ] i'm gonna die and it
was on
damn so you started with the ear yeah
that's why i [ __ ] with you right
a bit as numbers you burnt down your
irrational bit anything
i bit his balls his dick i ripped it cuz
the way you did it see listen
for a [ __ ] to bite a
[ __ ] it's one thing but the
bite and viciously rip rip a piece off
yeah you know i'm like yo what the [ __ ]
so now i know michael's like this
[ __ ] now mike keep it real
did you make the decision that this
[ __ ] gonna die
cause he hit you with a crazy blow and
rung your [ __ ] or did he cheat and head
butt
like what made you say dig right he was
head butting the [ __ ] out of me right
but that was cool too but the [ __ ] was
just ringing my [ __ ] belt
i was fighting this dude dude named
babyface from folk trade gang so many
dude used to fight all the time juvenile
and he wins some i'll lose some but one
time
i seen him and rushed him but i didn't
think he saw me right i mean the
[ __ ] caught me with some like a
combination from the the knuckles to the
elbow right
now mike you know what i'm saying i saw
a bunch of little bitty stars they was
everywhere
so what i did i said [ __ ] man this
[ __ ] knocked me i've never been
knocked out right
so i bagged up i said oh you hit like a
[ __ ] i'm really trying to recuperate
right
you know i see that muhammad ali's [ __ ]
so i told myself after that i never told
nobody this but i'm gonna keep it real
so we lock back up right so the police
break us up i was happy as a
[ __ ] they broke or up right
so when i go to the whole come back i
said [ __ ] i didn't [ __ ] this
[ __ ] like nine times we even
i'ma find a way to be this [ __ ]
friend cause that last time was the
first time i ever came close to being
knocked out
so i understand that [ __ ] brings that
anger in you it's like it scares you
but it makes you mad when you're a
warrior you know what i'm saying
yeah so mike telling me was rigging my
bell my [ __ ] [ __ ] goat
died yeah
[Laughter]
oh
yeah man shout out to soldier boy and
chris brown we almost had it
french [ __ ] how much money was hey i
ain't no this is real
boy i know these people's gonna pay
yo did you let him here i got the
recordings
you was training chris brown i got
evander holyfield to train
soldier boy they talked on the phone
listening
all that [ __ ] no but listen man
contracts listen
to these people 100 points want to see
these guys
fighting hey yo what's going to go down
round this no we can't [ __ ]
number now what's that guy because we
want to see these guys
who pulled out chris brown that's the
problem
[ __ ] that mike want to train chris brown
[ __ ] that
soldier boy i got evander on the phone
told him what it was
i said he said mike he said he said it
don't make sense
that while i'm training the rapper i
don't get it i said [ __ ] mike
tyson training upon he said what this
soldier boy on the phone
right now
i put mike and chris on the phone bro
chris brown well i know chris brown
wasn't scared
i just think he probably came to his
senses of of who he
was exactly to the to the commute to the
music chris brown is not your
he's like the bobby brown yeah what kind
of can you know him
who chris christie yeah yeah i got no i
don't know
and all this [ __ ] so i just think you
hung around cause like you chilled with
him before yeah i [ __ ] with chris
what kind of [ __ ] is that [ __ ] i mean
chris
is like i said he was like no he's you
know the last year
you ain't heard nothing but christmas
chris was the [ __ ] mike tyson i
remember
he was doing his thing we got caught up
with with the fight [ __ ] he's on some
other [ __ ] so
when he called soulja boy out i was
expecting soulja boy to be scared so
when i
do when i messed up when i thought it
was too when i remember with the little
homeboy shout out to wackstar
the futon he set the meeting up and that
[ __ ] soldier boy said
[ __ ] that with a contract i'm ready to
go right now
wow he said so i was assigned a soldier
boy he was assigned to chris brown me
and my wife drove way to [ __ ]
vegas to the mgm at home spot
and soldier boy came down signed it he's
sitting with chris brown
i sent him a screenshot chris brown
telling them in that [ __ ] ain't
gonna fight spreadsheet like [ __ ] i got
the contract right here he just signed
weak bro can you imagine soulja boy
chris brown mike tyson friend chris
[ __ ] evander claiming
everybody coming to the table man just
going down
listen since you know those guys right
and tell them they ain't gonna hurt it's
gonna be like with three rounds or so
you get any of those guys are [ __ ]
they're gonna make so much money they
might not even do music no more
no no for real no [ __ ] they might not do
music no more after that fight i was
gonna make a killer but i think chris
just kind of like
chris wanted him to just be like nah
that's stupid
not yeah but chris had called him out
but i think as time went
a week or two three weeks went chris
kind of like
came to because chris chris is really a
real intelligent
club but chris
you know chris get angry and chris you
know like all of us like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know he reacts you know i
think he reacted as
as he came down off of it he was like
man that ain't my [ __ ] leg
what was he mad about uh what the [ __ ]
would i think on my [ __ ] did he say
something was uh
or some [ __ ] yeah and at that time chris
brown was like real sensitive about that
i was just grug his woman he was in love
with the girl so
he kind of like took that [ __ ] personal
you know now listen let me tell you what
i was gonna do
i was representing soulja boy
but i was betting on chris bryant i
thought chris was gonna do it too but
chris said no i don't wanna do that
like i said i don't think chris didn't
do it because he didn't think he was
gonna win
i just think he kind of came to his
senses his mother probably talked to him
yeah you know somebody knows his stuff
and that's just what it was what's ready
to start managing he got a great manager
and probably yeah
good good soldier boy i mean chris was
ready to fight
yeah yeah he was gonna make some sweet
see crip's gonna walk away with 10 15
million [ __ ] dollars bro
i was gonna at least get two [ __ ] yeah
no hey hey how long was the training
the month no longer
i got to go take soldier boy some money
today i'm glad we talking about him
i like county jail put some money on his
books what the [ __ ]
finally got to get out oh he'd be out
next month they gave me they said
like 240. bob same [ __ ] didn't do his
community service had the forest
community service
somebody probably told on his ass and
then that's what it was and then he kept
getting a little problem you know when
you're on probation you got to like
square up you can't be [ __ ] around no
more you know what i'm saying oh when i
used to
community service it was the best [ __ ]
for me oh you you would used to go out
there for real
i used to go out to the community so
that do i go help some of the homeless
people
you probably loved it i loved the two
and sometime in those holding shows
there was some
some beautiful [ __ ] women they're
just homeless
hey listen i didn't confront confronted
my wife was homeless and i seen her i
definitely would have cleaned it
hey hey it's some dying pieces in there
shut off the sheet box
baby hey listen i'll put you in the
suite at the motel 6 for the first
couple days just to see you was gonna
run on me but
yeah i said what are you doing here i
think they were here helping like i was
they were in there i didn't know this
guy
wow oh [ __ ] you know we got the blue
foot blue face going on his first
headliner tour
star in july what's the song ethan
what's this so i see him on the bus
i don't know that song but i thought he
know how's it going singing there
bust down tatiana
he says crazy gangster [ __ ] some of the
music see what made me like him is that
he made me stop and rewind and say yo
what the [ __ ]
he's like he said [ __ ] like we're gonna
do mock the floor hide the west side
just to catch a [ __ ] slipping
so i'm like wait hold on what the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] said he gonna mock the
floor hide the west side to catch a
[ __ ] slipping right
listen he said some [ __ ] like i do a
[ __ ] cold and then i give her a blanket
you know like [ __ ] like that
you know he says cray like she called me
mama i don't even know her daddy you
know that kind of crazy [ __ ]
so he says crazy [ __ ] and it's kind of
like you know he's a character he's very
uh
you know that that's nephew i [ __ ] when
he's from school y'all crippled me
hustle was saying in his rap
his father met his mother at the century
because i said [ __ ] i need to hang out
with your club
every [ __ ] day every [ __ ] night
every night over day is
all night party never missed a [ __ ]
day in l.a yo listen mike said
i'll be in my limo and i'll go to
somebody's house drive her around as i
go stay at night and get back in my limo
drive around and go somebody else's
house
mike told us to mike tyson the real mike
tyson movie is coming
and the reason why i want to see it
because mike is the only boxer
who brings the whole culture together
you know what i'm saying yeah mike was
really a part of all that [ __ ] that was
going on like
mike was pulling up the [ __ ] projects
in the bins and getting out and
hitting the chirp to lock the door and
walking no security no nothing like
it was some regular [ __ ] so everybody
loved mike you know what i'm saying yeah
mike gonna stop in the middle of it and
have a conversation with his people so
he was never bigger than where his
people came from so we definitely
looking forward to that um
yeah it's gonna be awesome i came to l.a
in um 84 right for the olympic stuff
right
and so some girls we met some girls and
they started driving us in the city
beverly hills and stuff
and i'm saying wow but i never met
people that looked so nice before
these nice looking people these are
great dressing tanks and nice hair
driving their convertibles hanging out
and baby going to um
little you know i mean stands where they
have their food at and the shakes you
know
everybody looks nice everybody's smiling
at you it's friendly i thought i want to
move
here right and so i started boxing and
the next thing you know
86 i got married to this girl i moved in
oh wow dude microphone i never [ __ ]
left
how old were you in 84 i was 18 18.
and you know what else too the girls
were so [ __ ] because i ain't never
had no [ __ ] when the girl was so easy
to get [ __ ] and i said holy [ __ ]
i said oh [ __ ] i never had nobody in
there i gotta
[ __ ] so mike you got your first piece of
[ __ ] in in l.a
yeah wow oh [ __ ] [ __ ] it was like that
in new york
huh i ain't know the [ __ ] i was doing
the fight all the time man
and nobody wanted to give it up it's
hard to get man you got to talk to meet
their parents
all that stuff you know yes
always wanted to show up
[ __ ] abroad how does that affect you
when you train in box that doesn't
doesn't matter
so that's awesome [ __ ] it doesn't
affect you yeah
everything listens everything everything
performing sports singing everything
it's all about purity you know that all
comes from gotcha a divine perspective
country you know what i mean everything
from a period of perspective don't have
enough sex don't drink nothing don't do
this
before your sports don't do nothing they
have to be pure at this particular time
and that's just and that's just where
they're all mike you think floyd getting
back in the ring
absolutely yeah think so yeah what do
you think you should stop
when he's ready well yeah that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] can't hey listen
we say we say we're gonna stop but that
thing rings and you can't control it
gotcha you have no control over it yeah
yeah people say
they can't control shout out to floyd
shout out to my
florida's team over there how can you
get my boy back over there for that
moment for that 45 minutes whatever time
it is you're a god guys can you give
that up
no that's real yeah you never had it in
your [ __ ] bum
all your life you know where mom what do
you think about it right now yeah
mike what do you think about the uh you
gotta give that up you think about your
brother out of brooklyn in the
heavyweight brian's obama what do you
think about it oh
brooklyn wilder wow wow the wow doesn't
improve the lives oh he's improved man
he's improved a lot an improvement i was
talking about it like we're friend man
he did like
nice improvement i know one thing that
old school dude came up in there with
that [ __ ] and confused him a little
bit who's that
oh tyson fruit okay
he's doing some [ __ ] they're like you
know like in your mind
a lot of people didn't realize it was
close as it was
not because he was whooping dudes that
he was scoring
yeah he was scoring you know what i mean
so
he got dropped but he didn't knock him
out so it was it was
it was i wouldn't get back in the ring
with that old [ __ ] if i was here
you don't have to though everybody
listen it's just um fight is not like it
used to be everybody should always fight
the best the best
regardless of what team you're on if you
lose your man we fight again we build
them up and give them another fight
because it's all about really making
money you know yeah
you know nobody wants to lose but you're
going to stay you're going to stay
undefeated as long as you can't because
you're going to make the most money and
then one day you lose boom but you still
got that [ __ ] drawing call you can
still make the most money
it's all about making money exactly you
know what i mean when you're young
you're supposed to be the best the best
but it's all about making money that's
the whole objective making money that's
it you know but we getting our ego we
don't think about that no more when that
change
for you mike after you won it after you
won the title did you then
did it turn into a business or was it
always were you always business-minded
no i was always um
caught up with [ __ ] being this
[ __ ] figure and [ __ ]
yeah you know the best yeah mike took a
lot of people too
yeah oh yeah he was spending a lot of
money that's how you do you guys
like that if you got anybody else that's
how you got to do it it has to be that
way
but i think just as an athlete you you
know for so long it's about being the
best
but the guys who do it for the longest
or the guys who realize oh this is a
business is about making money
absolutely and then they start to treat
it that way
absolutely you know we take advantage of
our celebrity
we use ourselves we hurt ourselves we
know the people who love us the people
are going to pay to see us
but i'm not my best i'm not going to
give them right i'm going to be my best
for them but still they're going to pay
because they're
they're they're romantically involved
with me they have a perspective about me
that's not even true
yeah listen at mike's age right now how
true that is
if harmony vander said right now
fighting pay-per-view sound like
[ __ ] ghosts sell it out
you know halloween coming up so i was
wondering if i can do something with you
to patent
the halloween ear we're going to call it
the evander
because i don't know maybe the mic you
know what i'm saying
and it's just gonna be like half of the
ear gone you know what i'm saying
but we're gonna dedicate you know what
i'm saying all right you ain't tripping
aren't you not uh
there we go halloween are you coming
with the evanna holyfield here listen
coming
coming um halloween 2019.
like um like two hundred dollars a while
hundred eight dollars a whop
um how many people here i took a picture
waiting
for oh yeah oh my god
the committee [ __ ] the committee
oh that's it yeah you gotta give a three
million dollars [ __ ]
um [ __ ] good [ __ ] man i enjoyed myself
man this was a great
that's just my first podcast never did a
part man you guys think
you talked about wanting to be out there
you got your three points podcasts are
bigger
bigger than being in the news station
you need yours
yeah yeah my [ __ ] is
you want to be on the scene this is what
it is i [ __ ] me up so i didn't think
about that i thought
let's go to it's called a news station
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
where is that more people are looking at
this news would
yeah that's real because it never goes
away it's always gonna live on that
planet yeah
hey brother thank you so much man nah
that's all
crunchy [ __ ] thank you dude man you got
me on camera man
[ __ ] that frenchie mike yeah what
did you meet frenchie's woman man nah
[ __ ] we ain't me
[ __ ] imaginary [ __ ] woman so i'm
thinking he's opening up another mike
tyson's fitness
this is imaginary woman i don't think
this chick exists man
she's on the plane all the time
is she australian no she's from africa
she's from zimbabwe oh listen right oh
this is what
i'm wearing
this is what i know what's going on all
over the world right now in australia
they have a big epidemic with
sudanian africans yes it's gangster
and the people they're not as bad as the
people say but they get bad reputation
people making up [ __ ] about them they're
really
[ __ ] up people some of them probably
are but these yeah the majority of them
are just good oh they're getting [ __ ]
they don't have no fathers in the house
most of their fathers died in the war so
it's just a mother raising you can't
raise no young boy when he comes to life
he's going to go out into the world and
with the skills he knows which is
nothing he's going to get in some [ __ ]
yeah
and that's what's happening at it you
know they're fearless of the cops
cops don't have guns there i don't
believe damn you know about the sudanese
like things over there that's crazy i
got youtube i know any actions
just for the russia because i didn't
know uh
miss frenchy i didn't know so i kind of
like made him available to the world
come on man i'm just saying like when
you're gonna bring her to meet the
family like what to do
yeah she's coming you get some babies
out here
yeah listen right i remember some little
frenchies
you know what i'm saying we call him
frenchy you know he's from the congo he
speaks
fluent french yeah
you know what i'm saying that's because
that's because the french colony
colonized them yeah yeah you know french
like some african colonies only speak
english yeah
true because english colonize though
they colonized our family what's the
native language congolese
lingala but you guys don't know that but
he's from congo i'm congratulations he's
from coco
really yeah he is that's cool
23 and me yeah you can do like different
yeah i definitely want to do that it's
from congo yeah
man shout out to them crazy
[ __ ] that brought us from the
africans
because without all that [ __ ] we went
through the slave trade and all that
[ __ ]
none of us be sitting here right now not
in the united states of america
you gotta look at stuff like this no
look at it this you know
um
it's very interesting when you say that
because um we
from all about experience in life you
know you me everything
you know when you're mothers and family
when you're kidding everything seeing
people pass away that you love
everything and you say to yourself
hey what happens after this is over yeah
it's real
i mean what's the real deal you know we
talk a lot [ __ ] we say you know when
it's gone it's gone i'm ready to go see
allah whatever but you know what do we
expect
what do we prepare to expect for yeah i
know this is not over like boom because
i'm
probably our bodies going yeah but you
know what this [ __ ] don't know
if you drift off
hey listen i got this [ __ ] up thing
you get a bunch of [ __ ] up [ __ ] in
life
they turn your ass into a chicken or
something [ __ ]
right a rock a rock the mountain
just you know i'm saying i don't know
what you're right i know what's the iron
this is so ironic that i found out which
blows my mind
if all the ants on this planet died all
of us would die
if all the fish in the ocean died all of
us died if all the trees would
die we were the planets everything is
needed if all of us died
would flourish damn yeah that's real if
all of us died the planet don't give up
it's going to flourish that's right i
mean so the plans don't need it so what
is our purpose here
yeah that's real hey we need to find a
[ __ ] goat don't need to drive a
road everything else
everything else is we [ __ ] everything
else become extinct
the planet's dead everything else
anything else on this planet
the species become extinct the planet is
dead but
human beings we thought it's going to
flourish more yeah
it doesn't need us why are we here why
does it put us through all the things we
see lovers once
died in front of us and we panic we lose
our mind and then we die why are we here
to see all that let's do it
that's real what is that what is that
purpose here for us really make a whole
bunch of money he's gonna die anyway
ain't gonna enjoy it really and that's
what's gonna happen
that's real and then when you look at
you get 50 things while this is on my
sofa
no that's some real [ __ ] because when
you're 18 19 you can't even see 50.
no 50 years old 42.44 yeah you see that
[ __ ] coming around the corner but you
still feel great yeah
so you said what why is that still i
can't i know i feel invincible
at 40. yeah that's true
man listen it was nice being here it's
awesome i know my wife got to go to this
yeah
that's right i got a red i got a red
flight to [ __ ] new york tonight
hell yeah brother you know spend a lot
of time myself yeah i'm always in new
york
that's awesome always love new york it's
dope man
shout out to nyc all day brooklyn
brownsville brooklyn baby
yeah never ran never all right mike you
still got that crazy ass pitching
[ __ ] cage you had in vegas yeah you
moved it out here
no no any mover has to have it there so
you're going back check it out go back
and check them back i have somebody take
care of them though
nice [ __ ] mike pigeons drink
[ __ ] what is it poor female pg water
mike pigeons drink fiji water they
really
hell yeah
he need to get a sponsorship for that
[ __ ] yeah man yeah though
my birthday the oldest thing i had in my
life
always been there day one yeah nine
years old i had birds it's amazing
any of the same ones no but just my
whole life i always had birds what's
their lifespan
i had about 20 years old before wow 16
17.
that's cool you know in the while they
don't live much they only probably three
years or something oh really if they're
lucky
[ __ ] man great episode we gotta do this
[ __ ] again man
definitely hell yeah brother come back
any time man like with your
blue face love it bring back man that
blue face back oh yeah
that's the boy in his mouth all right
what did birdman do man what's happening
with him man birdman him and slim me you
know they made me the vp of cash money
so i started cash money
what kind of relationship you got with
lil wayne uh well i got a great
relationship with little white
birdman and lil wayne talking they don't
speak in terms now they talk to texts
slim always been on speaking terms with
everybody you know birdman and um
him and tony braxton man you know they
real happy together you know i mean so
he's been he just kind of rejoined his
life and laying back and doing what he's
doing and still
allowing us to utilize his platform
meant to continue music
and giving us an opportunity that we
probably wouldn't got with anybody else
longevity man you know what i'm saying
so you know shout out to birdman the
whole cash money
tony braxton slim you know what i mean
shout out to everybody on their side man
we love you [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying no he gonna come up too i'm
definitely hopeful yeah bring him
bring him all right man shout out to
mike tyson
tyson ranch coming soon hell yeah yo
fred frenchy mike tyson fitness center
and you know what i'm gonna use this to
publish this face [ __ ] don
king okay okay another great episode of
hot boxing
i'm mike tyson i'm evan britton and we
are here
hey ouch peace